10 Cloverfield Lane tells a small story
designed to stand on its own but it's
also deceptively full of complex plot
twists potent but understated themes and
if you hidden ties to a larger
Cloverfield mythology let's unlock this
bunker of secrets and explain the ending
of 10 Cloverfield Lane though they seem
to have nothing in common on the surface
a look back at Cloverfield may provide
some clues about the aims of 10
Cloverfield Lane the original movie is
about a giant monsters arrival in New
York City
that's just a backdrop to the main drama
through its found-footage conceit
Cloverfield showcases a group of
20-somethings sending off their friend
Rob as he prepares to move to Japan to
start a new job clover fields inventive
first-person angle on a classic Godzilla
formula makes it an effective thrill
ride but it's the naturalistic depiction
of young adults in 2008 America that
gives it a surprising amount of weight
in short it's a giant sci-fi blockbuster
interrupting an intimate indie drama
about people struggling with regrets
their perspectives are shaken and shaped
by unimaginable horror making their real
needs clear for the first time that
brings us to the sequel 10 Cloverfield
Lane introduces us to a heroine in a
hurry in the opening sequence Michelle
is anxiously packing a suitcase her eyes
darting to the stormy horizon outside is
she desperate to escape a monster
invasion as it turns out she's fleeing
from an ill-fated proposal and ignoring
calls from her boyfriend leaving behind
an engagement ring and taking a bottle
of whiskey she hits the highway out of
New Orleans in the midst of the drama
that will soon follow it might be easy
to lose track of just how much is being
set up about Michelle's character here
the fashion sketches seem strewn around
her apartment the radio news reports
about massive blackouts and even the
bottle of whiskey are all elements that
will pay off later most importantly we
learn from her boyfriend's call that she
has an apparent chronic problem with
commitment it's clear that his words
strike a chord with her as she grows
increasingly distracted listening to his
voice from behind the wheel we had
couples fight there is no reason to just
leave everything behind running away
isn't gonna helping it so distracted in
fact that she's unprepared for the truck
that sideswipes her into a violent wreck
michelle wakes up in a strange
cinderblock room that's half gray and
half painted pink and some sort of sad
attempt at cheery femininity she's
hooked up to an IV drip and her leg
injured in the crash is in a brace but
the brace is chained to the wall someone
has saved her life but is also holding
her captive that someone is Howard
Stambler Howard soon explains that he's
taken Michelle into his private
underground bunker in the aftermath of
some sort of attack he's fuzzy on the
details muttering theories about
everything from Russians to Martians
Howard is known for years that something
was coming though and has been preparing
for this day Michelle's room we
gradually learned was supposed to be for
his daughter Megan why isn't Megan here
instead according to Howard her mother
turned her against him it's an
explanation couched in the disturbingly
familiar language of abuse before she
can come to any conclusions about
whether or not she trusts Howard
Michelle becomes aware of a third person
in their midst
Emmet's is a young man who helped build
Howard's bunker and made his way to it
as soon as loud sounds and lights in the
sky signal the onslaught of whatever
invasion has occurred friendly and naive
and it quickly becomes Michelle's ally
and solving the bunkers mysteries it may
not be immediately clear but Emmitt
serves a few functions in the story his
most obvious purpose is to give Michelle
support and someone to talk to as she
navigates her situation he also provides
some important exposition informing
Michelle that Howard was always known
for his doomsday prepper mentality and
eventually sharing an important
revelation about a photo that Howard
claims is of his daughter Megan most
ominously it's significant that Howard
seems to barely tolerate Emmett's
presence
Howard's consistent irritation toward
Emmitt suggests that he has more
specific goals with the punker than
saving lives unsurprisingly Michelle
remains hesitant to trust the man who
chained her to a wall and told her
Martians may have attacked she remains
not entirely convinced by his stories
even after he brings her to the bunkers
heavy locked door to show her a pair of
mutilated pigs outside as evidence of
what the air itself will do to anyone
who breathes it so at the first
opportunity she bashes him in the
and Krabs his keys and makes a break for
the door but before she can open it
she's met by a woman begging to be let
in screaming and desperate as the skin
seemingly melts from her face fully
convinced that the air outside is indeed
dangerous
Michelle resigns herself to remaining in
the bunker the decision is made easier
by a seemingly softened attitude from
Howard who stalks her through the
process of stitching up the head injury
she caused while sharing stories about
his time in the Navy they soon enough
move on from the disturbing death
they've witnessed but the memory lingers
over the film until the very end as the
only two people who can relate to each
other
Michelle and Emmet naturally end up
sharing stories about their lives before
the bunker they talk about tattoos
they've always wanted with Emmet saying
that he would have gotten plenty if he
had known the attack was going to happen
when asked if he has any regrets Howard
replies everything I wanted to do I did
I focused on being prepared and I was
and here we are later after the
occurrence with a woman at the door and
it tries to comfort Michelle by assuring
her that there was nothing she could
have done to help this brings up more
talk of regrets
Michelle is haunted by the time she saw
a little girl being abused by her father
and did nothing to help while Emmet's
life was changed when a lack of
confidence stopped him from getting on a
bus to start college at Louisiana Tech
Michelle and Emmet settle in for life
with Howard though the piece remains
uneasy in a particularly uncomfortable
game night Howard fails to associate the
word woman with Michelle struggling with
words like girl and princess it's a
disturbing indication of how much she's
infantilized her the tension comes to a
head when Michelle tasked with crawling
through the bunkers vents to fix an air
filter discovers a window to the outside
into which someone has scratched the
word help nearby she finds a bloody
earring which she recognizes from
Howard's photo of Megan but when she
shows the pitcher to Emmet he recognizes
the girl not as Megan but as a classmate
of his sisters who disappeared from the
area sometime back regardless of how
correct he might be about the dangers
outside it's now clear to Michelle and
Emmet how dangerous Howard is he's been
using the bunker to hold young women
captive in a deluded attempt to replace
his daughter and Michelle is next
Michelle has a plan she envisions a May
shift hazmat suit and vision from the
bunker shower curtain and various
household items GM at begin assembling
the materials while abating Howard's
notice unfortunately it doesn't work for
long and Howard calls the two of them up
to help him move a barrel inside the
barrel is an acid capable of dissolving
human bodies down to the bone
Howard makes it clear that he knows that
Michelle and Emmet are up to something
and that if they don't confess they'll
end up in the barrel Emmet accepts all
responsibility for the plan and Howard
accepts his apology by calmly shooting
him in the head
Howard insists to a shocked Michelle
that like everything else he's done this
to protect her soon after he undergoes
some sort of bizarre dad transformation
appearing clean shaven and neatly
dressed for the first time is the office
Michelle ice cream the uneasy tension of
his demeanor has been replaced by an
even more terrifying sense of total
unchallenged delusion but Michelle's
real call to action comes in a silent
scene that vines are going through
Emmett's belongings and finding the bus
tickets to Louisiana Tech he's been
holding on to for all these years her
resolve is bolstered with the
uncertainty of the world outside leaving
the bunker is less about saving her own
life than it is about not letting regret
to find her death the film's climax
kicks off when Howard discovers
Michelle's nearly complete hazmat suit
and she narrowly escapes his wrath by
momentarily trapping him in her room
when he breaks free in corners are near
the perchloric acid she has no choice
but to push a barrel over starting a
fire as soon as the acid hits an
electrical outlet
fleeing through the vents from a burned
and furious Howard Michelle uses the can
of liquid nitrogen to break the exits
massive padlock and at last escape this
final flights out of the bunker is fast
and intense but a careful retracing of
the movie's plot reveals just how much
of it has been setup all along
Michelle is successfully constructed a
hazmat suit thanks to her interest in
fashion design that's part of her
character from the very beginning her
knowledge of the ventilation layout is
established by the earlier filter repair
sequence one of the film's most intense
moments in its own right and the liquid
nitrogen trick was subtly foreshadowed
by Howard's casual aside about doing the
same thing in the Navy michelle has
spent her time in captivity learning
everything she needed to survive and the
open air of howard's farm Michelle
Wheatly panics when a whole tears in her
suit but the sight of birds flocking
overhead unharmed tips are off that the
air may not be as toxic as she believed
sure enough she removes her makeshift
plastic bottle facemask and can breathe
without trouble but then a horn sounds
nearby alerting her to the presence of
an enormous alien craft sailing over the
crops as darkness falls another ship
rises up from behind the house and an
enormous tentacle beast emerges Michelle
takes shelter in Howard's truck and
though the creature lifts it up and
nearly devours her she has one more
trick up her sleeve and it's yet another
plot point set up in the movies earliest
scenes with a bottle of whiskey she took
with her when she left home she fashions
a Molotov cocktail that not only burns
the alien but causes a chain reaction
with the gases in its body obliterating
the monster and a huge explosion the
most important reason for 10 Cloverfield
Lane surprising final sequence though is
to bring Michelle's character arc to a
significant final moment she commandeers
the car left behind by the woman at the
bunkers door at first following radio
instructions for survivors to gather at
Baton Rouge her escape is interrupted by
another radio message silently
reflecting on how everything that's
happened to her has given her exactly
the necessary skills she turns toward
Houston as stormy skies reveal more
ships looming in the distance the movie
ends on this moment of decision with our
heroine barreling toward danger it's far
more than an open-ended sequel set up
however it's the first time Michelle is
committed to facing a problem head-on
instead of running from danger or
difficulty we've watched her go from a
scared uncertain person wracked with
regret to a decisive competent hero
ready to give herself over to a noble
cause everything about her time in the
bunker her battle with Howard and her
honesty with Emmet has brought her to
this place check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stop or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]